she's walking down a hundred and tenth
Street she's causing new potholes the
Ninja Turtles are having to do new
drywall and she's upset that people
found her attractive I hear a lot of
people upset about the fat pride issue
fat shaming and I want everyone I want
to know why whichever side you're on
what is it about the other side that
upsets you because this is an issue
where there's a lot of controversy but
sometimes school can't articulate why
exactly I'll tell you exactly what it is
for me it's a compulsion of language
it's not about it's not about chubby
women it's not about mansplaining here's
here's what I think people need to
remember most men find most women
attractive yeah okay everyone in this
room has who has a girlfriend or
mother's sister's I can think everyone
right just connecting from us at least
12 women a variance of 8 inches in
probably 60 pounds between them and all
of them would be considered attractive
somebody says we do not expect women to
look or be one way men don't expect that
my problem with the fat pride movement
is when you demand that we deem all
women to be attractive in all ways it's
the compulsion of language reasonable
let me know so here is what's happening
right now there's a show on Netflix
again launching called insatiable and
there's there's already a petition to
stop it let's roll a clip so you have
some context for it my name is patty
high school was a nightmare fatty
Betty's huge every day I wonder how much
more is this can I take right here
having my jaw wired shut
lost me more than just my summer
vacation now I could be the former fatty
who turned into a brain we're an athlete
princess we have that enough of this you
can go I don't even think the show is
out yet if I'm not mistaken yeah doesn't
stop people from already being outraged
do the tweets my favorite one here is it
says this is still telling kids to lose
weight to win hmm yes you lose weight
the response really shouldn't be all
that surprising giving the long list of
fat pride leading romantic comedies this
brings us to this week's seven plus one
always one in the chamber and by the way
we have like three magazines today just
so you know but these are these were the
most popular of course fat pride films
annual don't realize number seven was a
size 27 dresses and number six is
actually a sequel to another one but
you've got heart disease that was a big
green bottom I guess number five she's
all fat okay number four The Devil Wears
Lane Bryant without you that's just me
number two isn't she chubby a lot of
people weren't entirely sure
Edward Edward Byrnes isn't she lovely I
don't know I don't know he was Freddie
Prinze jr. number one how to crush a guy
in ten seconds okay reload back to
number seven oh we have so many of these
13 going on diabetes was a really
popular one for a while
number six number two number six father
of the fat bride they were pretty much
yeah different different that point they
weren't even really original no it was
like doing the Ocean's eleven with women
only
number five failure to lunch that was
one and it's a ill-fated sequel number
four I took care of it so number three
all-you-can-eat breakfast brunch lunch
winner dinners second in her cocktail
hour midnight snack at Tiffany's that
was one she also was really racist with
the fat Asian Mickey Rooney yeah yeah
that was very incentive John used
classic number 216 cheeseburgers Oh
mixes again with the racist aging again
with the Asian care but hilarious seven
less that was fat Duk dong number one
there girl interrupted by a coronary
reload we have another seven for you
number seven
while you were sleeping I rated the
fridge was another one number six yeah
portly woman that was one that Jason
Alexander a little-known fact in that
film number five yeah he played the
portly woman is true can't runaway bride
that was one struggles Oh number four
fifty shades of grey fat version not any
that's like the expurgated version of
Fifty Shades of Grey with fat storing
Lena don't think they're getting lazy
and desperate yeah it's almost I think
some of these are straight to video
number three The Sisterhood of the
unnecessary but actually necessary
maternity pants
number two PSI eight you and this is it
was actually sequel no way I always get
these confused when Harry but when
Sleepless in Seattle was not actually
one but uh number one was when Harry fed
Sally that was the big one and of course
actually the the plus one top rom-com
fat pride film of all time is I feel
pretty startled me shimmer that's this
week seven plus one always forget that's
how it ends all the villains the Germans
you're out no I'm not
by the way hit the bell join mug club if
you haven't the notification bell that's
what you keep it going we do able to
show every single day full hour and if
you want to try it out live streams
every Thursday's 8 p.m. Eastern okay so
I think the fat pride issue this really
is more symptomatic of the left and it's
the root causes here are greed
enablement and ingratitude and these are
the same things with was every other
promise you from the left so what
happens if someone is greedy and you
enable them it all ultimately
to complete and total ingratitude yeah
how do I mean this greed let's let's
start with the left it lets go
economically and then move into fat
pride yeah for example today's
progressive left they accuse the wealthy
of being greedy but the wealthy aren't
the ones trying to take anything from
you we talk about the wealthy the 1% I
think its joint depending which number
used 300 something thousand or 400
something thousand joint household
income yeah they pay most of the taxes
okay we're not talking about the
economic system and justice or someone
who works Bear Stearns we understand but
the truth is when you just look at the
general population it's the progressive
leftists we're the ones trying to take
what others have earned health care
universal income internet and of course
the green parallels was with obesity
you're the great a pig who ate too much
so not obese people are not trying to
take your food you're taking they're
just not on board with it so then it
leads us to enable MIT with the fat
pride issue I think that's probably the
one that people are the most obvious the
Left enables bad behavior because it
feels good yeah as long as it feels good
it's about rather than examining
themselves and reflecting but good oK
we've done this but how much luck have
we caught for this let's use a few
examples aids aids with something
specific behavioral patterns lead to
catching AIDS
don't judge it's it's perfectly
legitimate of lifestyles anyone else is
it okay how about a vision we should all
be getting a lucky I'll get a oh by the
way said I think two and five
heterosexual couples by like 1995 we
have that zero just Stephen King
advertisement surplus you had to give
out hey by the way the lifestyle is
called not having sex with men and truck
stop stalls yeah yeah that's it it's the
single most preventable disease in human
history a hundred percent preventable
how about instead we have a pill how
about you just how about you just don't
have orgies and tricks us let's go at
the pill okay I mean obviously abortion
yeah you have no right to judge it's
just as moral of a choice that whether
you're pro-life or pro-choice listen you
have the right to judge we've enabled
women to make it as easy actually easier
than putting a child up for adoption
your if you're a see really unemployed
loser
let's just keep them Universal income
right but you don't you don't know if
that's the word right nuance you were in
Anika its new everything is nuanced
giant fat Lana
who are you to judge they're just as
healthy and beautiful as everyone else
by the way they want to change it from
diabetes to live a biddies is actually
better yeah but that sounds better dye
is more you still lose absorptive though
yeah and this this leads us to
ingratitude and rather than you know
just becoming a manatee you know or
being grateful that you live in a
country with even the option to become
obese that's one gun to the left is
constant America is the fattest Super's
what I think it's a great thing that we
have the problem of overabundance right
yeah I'm still grossed out but I think
it's a good problem to have better than
starvation and you have all of the tools
readily available to fix it instead
people [ __ ] hey [ __ ] because you now
feel entitled to not only a seriously
great health risk but entitled to other
people's opinions regarding your beauty
that's the issue here you demanded the
public opinion change in the face of
evolutionary biology and by the way
scientific medical consensus not only
let's let's not even say consensus
Medical accuracy truth it doesn't matter
who agrees on it
I've never the problem it's society that
has to be changed to accommodate that
instead of dropping a few pounds we have
to make although these they don't
airplane seats bigger these same people
always bitching about privilege how
privileged are the more time to fat is
the proper your privileged and your
exercising it more because I actually
like the roomy seats we kind of all
benefit the issues we go even as far as
to shame those people who take care of
their bodies Yeah right now people that
they're famous they try to say sin
privilege so we can't we can't shame
people for eating themselves into
obesity and I'm not saying you should
shame people but you can't even make a
judgement saying this is a bad call
yeah but we can shame people who
exercise enough that they can have a
slice of pizza on the weekend for
example and tolerance yeah look at that
idea so the definition I think it
happened in front of me is yeah sympathy
or indulgence for beliefs or practices
differing from a conflicting opinion
with one's own the allah the act of
Allah I don't even think that's gonna be
in the nomenclature for our kids no
tolerance used to be you know don't make
fun of fat people we all agree don't be
a bully
of course that's fine listen I was
chubby 7th 8th 9th grade I was short fat
then really tall and skinny I didn't
shave
21 the definition is that the act of
celebrating everything exactly that's a
big difference the left doesn't even
allow differing opinions anymore yeah
they're blatant in the fact that they
must engineer public opinion to match
theirs exactly or they will guess like
you right let's go from gay marriage too
many little girls rooms now taxing the
wealthy to being forced to praise now
it's not you don't believe me it's
forced praise of morbidly obese people
instead of weigh-ins Napa has yay yay
between sexy and between diabetes type 2
and death rot is just a simple answer no
you're not this land well who marched
down Times Square in a bikini right it's
care from Cosmo and she complained that
she was actually people were actually
calling yeah you know like they wanted
to get all up in her in her crevices and
stuff for whatever it was um
I mean here's a woman who like a
crevasse is she's walking down 110
Street she's causing new potholes the
Ninja Turtles are having to do new
drywall and she's upset that people
found her attractive this is the problem
people have it's the commitment it's a
component of the definition of Tolerance
is predicated on idea of understanding
and compromise we just talked about so
tell me where is it we just talked about
gay marriage transgender issues wealth
redistribution right now fat pride tell
me where is the Alford compromise from
the left on any of those issues I just
mentioned any of those issues I just
mentioned you have to tolerate they have
to be willing to find a middle ground
name one you can't force people to
accept someone you can't force an
apology you can't force people to love
someone and you can't force people to be
sexually attracted to it by the way this
is the thing most guys are sexually
attracted to most women you don't have
to be perfect we just don't want to have
to be told that we're racist sexist
misogynistic Pig if we are not attracted
to all of the things and that's by the
way it's just itself some medical
accuracy that's why Amazon Prime
recently really think they struggled
with their recent docu-series
celebrating obese seventy five year olds
it's not going down the plank anytime
soon
if you liked this video subscribe or
click the notification button next to
the subscribe button because YouTube's
decided that subscribing doesn't mean
anything if you want actually know about
our videos coming out you have to the
notification button also if you're a fan
you want the daily late night show
subscribe to mug Club at ladder with
CARICOM slash mug club thanks for
stopping but this is just it's goofy